what do some writers get wrong with
flashbacks and some are good at that's
an excellent question that is something
that many writers struggle with the
flashback sequence and
you have to recognize when you have a
flashback you are interrupting the flow
of story
so if you're going to interrupt the
momentum in the present moment it has to
be something that is advancing the plot
in the present by going to the past and
many writers will make the mistake of
not understanding that for the first
thing and then they'll have flashbacks
where there's not an arc of the
flashback and when you have flashbacks
you need to go through the thinking of
how is this advancing my plot is this is
going to take the audience out of story
so is it paralleling the Arc in a way
that there's a value in going to the
past is a way to better understand and
add depth to the present so the
character can get to the Future
if I remember correctly I know we were
talking about Emily the criminal um off
camera yes we don't really see
flashbacks of what her and initial
dilemma was right
and I think that makes it so interesting
it really keeps you hooked it does like
the the interesting thing is so and I
have
there are many writers who will say why
do you have to have a wound do you have
to have a wound do you have to go into
the past how come the present Arc can't
carry that weight
and the answer to that is the present
Arc if it is a compelling enough dilemma
and we feel it in the framework of the
setup can carry a lot of that the value
of
understanding through not going to
flashback and like in a character like
you mentioned through not going to the
flashback but putting the weight in the
present Arc but maybe through dialogue
and character dynamic in the present we
are feeling the void of the past through
Choice through action without having to
go there or to know anything specific
because we are seeing it and writers
have perfected I have seen writers
certainly when you look at the genre of
the action film you are often looking at
you're not going to go into the but but
I even think the action film has evolved
in a way to where we do feel the earlier
wound and there are different methods
that were able to thread together the
emotional Arc in the same way so I think
that show did does a brilliant job of
setting up a strong enough dilemma in
the present where we feel something from
past without having to flash back
right because if I remember correctly
her dilemma which we weren't sure if we
were going to see the flashback is
brought up a few times and it's hinted
at or it's directly talked about but we
never it really is this thing that keeps
you hooked and
um you know the opening scene if I
remember correctly was the job interview
and I thought that was just so brilliant
how it was played out yeah I agree so so
I think it can work it can work and I
think also like you tapped into
something the the idea of the puzzle of
story
what are you creating that is creating
anticipation that the audience is
playing a mind game through what you're
revealing in the present that makes you
curious about the past when you look at
a show uh like the flight attendant and
you start with a flashback
uh we you start with the flaw we see the
very flawed Behavior with her
promiscuity and her parting and her
drinking in the beginning so you start
with the flaw the flaw is the story of
the wound so that creates anticipation
then we get a hint of a flashback about
her with her father and the idea of a
deer I think is the first flashback and
then by the climax we learn that she
lost her father but that's not giving
giving us the whole thing that's giving
us two pieces of the puzzle which is
creating a curiosity which is creating
anticipation for the series Arc which
we're going to get the full story of
what happened to Emily's father
how does that connect with her flawed
behavior that we see from the start and
how does the pursuit allow her an
opportunity to heal
so do you think flashbacks are effective
when they're hinted at
I do and I also encourage writers to
think about how can you use your
background
and
the character action and choice to tell
a story without having to go to the
flashback so for example something that
was so brilliant with uh the split was
and I missed it the first time I saw the
the first episode was when you opened
you saw Hannah and her husband were
opposite ends of the bed and you felt
the void in the middle and then you cut
to a series of pictures of Hannah and
her sisters and her mom and then there's
a picture where you can see that the
father was cut out
and that was a hint
without us knowing yet what specifically
happened we're like huh what was that
you know so I think that
when you quietly give us information
from the past in the present there's a
tremendous value if you do it in a way
artistically that creates a curiosity
and an anticipation from the audience
so yeah don't be too overt with the
flashbacks yes interesting yeah and
I believe that there there is a value to
flashbacks uh you're going to have many
development Executives who will say
don't flash back don't do voiceovers
that's lazy writing yeah I I hear it
over and over and over again from
writers who tell me that they're they're
hearing these instructions and then you
watch the Golden Globes you watch the
Emmys you watch the Oscars and stories
that have flashbacks are the stories
that are hitting in the deepest way the
message is don't gratuitously take us to
the Past only take us to the past if
there's value in the present story
yeah so any any type of especially like
with an orphan story like with forgive
me I'm blanking on the name with Dev
Patel and um Nicole Kidman uh yes yes
that one a very effective uh flashback
because you need it that was like a
double narrative that that was very
effective in the recognition if I
remember correctly I think that or no it
was
it was linear but there but we needed we
were in the past
before but that that inciting incident
was so powerful with what happened that
changed the trajectory of the of the
boy's life
sure and in Queens Gambit as well
another orphan story we we needed to
know certain things about how the mom
felt and her sort of world view Queens
Gambit is brilliant the Queen's Gambit I
was so emotionally
connected to that story and and what
they utilized that was so valuable is we
We're In the Heat of the wound when it
happened
and we felt it and we like were were
like you're you're in when you feel the
wind In the Heat of the Moment that it
happens and then you have the puzzle of
what didn't I know that transpired
before and after that moment that is
going to affect the present plot and you
bring us to those gaps then we're in and
and there's a value in that the uh there
was a show with Maggie Gyllenhaal called
an honorable woman if I remember
correctly where it starts in and it's
not con when you start in the wound
it's not considered a flashback if you
start in the childhood wound and then
you cut to 25 years later
then you give us that peace that we need
without having to go to a flashback
you're in real time when the wound
happens
then there was a transition so in an
honorable woman we see a little girl a
little boy their father they sit down to
this formal dinner at the shishi place
and the waiter suddenly stabs the father
and we see the blood go on the little
girl and then we cut to Maggie
Gyllenhaal in her 20s in the same place
that she was when her father was killed
and the parallel of what led to her
father's life and a choice that she was
making in the series setup was linked
so by literally giving us that page and
a half two pages you make it we're in
like you're like I want to be a part of
this character character's Pursuit I
want to know how does a character move
Beyond a trauma like that without having
to and then it did go into a double
narrative where you understood a
different point in time and how it
paralleled what was going on with the
present plot and there was tremendous
value because of the multi-dimensions